outwardly Democrats seem united in their
loathing for Donald Trump
but inside the party Democrats may in
fact hate each other more even more than
they hate Trump how vicious and crazy
has the infighting within the Democratic
Party become let's put it this way late
last week Hillary Clinton publicly
accused a Democratic presidential
candidate of being a Russian agent watch
I'm not making any predictions but I
think they've got their eye on somebody
who's currently in the Democratic
primary and are grooming her to be the
third party candidate she's a favorite
of the Russians well later a spokesman
confirmed Hillary was in fact talking
about tulsi gabbard of Hawaii now keep
in mind that Gabbard is a sitting member
of Congress she's an Iraq war veteran
she's currently a major in the US Army
Reserves and yet Hillary said she's a
traitor to this country and she's not
the only one in American politics of
betraying our country Jill Stein to
Stein of course spent decades working as
a physician in Boston before embarking
on a second career as a left-wing
activist last cycle she ran for
president on a platform that includes a
green New Deal Medicare for all
amnesty for the undocumented the normal
list but according to Hillary Jill Stein
is also a Russian agent watch they have
a bunch of sites and BOTS and other ways
of supporting her so far and that's
assuming Jill Stein will give it up
which she might not because she's also a
Russian writer yeah yeah she's a Russian
asset I mean totally Stein is also a
Russian asset end quote
she and tulsi gabbard the Russian assets
now some of the left are denying that
Hillary Clinton said that she certainly
did say it you just heard it the tape is
online you could listen for yourself and
then she kept going the president United
States Hillary Clinton explained is
being blackmailed by Vladimir Putin
himself Donald Trump is Vladimir Putin's
dream I don't know what Putin has on him
whether it's both personal and financial
I assume it is well in case you're
trying to keep track at home in a single
podcast
Clinton accused three separate people
one to her left one to her right one
within her own party all of being
Russian agents now she offered precisely
no evidence for these charges seriously
though they are the one thing that all
three of these people have in common is
that at one time or another they have
all opposed
Hillary Clinton's political aspirations
and according to Hillary that means by
definition they're traitors now remember
as you watch this that Hillary Clinton
is supposed to be a very impressive
person her fellow liberals have told us
that since she graduated from Wellesley
College more than fifty years ago and
then went on to Yale Law School famously
and married Bill Clinton she is then is
now one of the best and the brightest
she's the adult in the room that's what
they always tell you and yet now we
learned they were lying about Hillary
all along she's not impressive she's
silly she's reckless she's not even very
smart like dumb people ever hear she's
got a weakness for bizarre conspiracies
that's the real Hillary Clinton and yet
amazingly her fellow liberals are still
defending her Hillary's been dead on
with so many things she told us about
Russia she told us about the probable
interference during the debate she was
Secretary of State she has deep
knowledge about world issues I thought
where's the lie you have her being
touted by people like Fox Fox News
personalities like Tucker Carlson the
Russian propaganda machine has been
propelling her lifting her up since she
announced her candidacy she never denied
being a Russian asset would be the first
you know in the first line or two it was
not there do your Clinton didn't name
name but there's the congresswoman
Gabbard who like me she never denied
being a Russian asset that's the new
standard so she must be guilty that's
what they're telling you know on MSNBC
Julian Castro who as of tonight is still
an actual presidential candidate
essentially agreed do you agree with
former Secretary of State Clinton that
she could very well be a Russian asset
I'm gonna focus today on my campaign and
what we're doing just to confirm you did
not say no you do not think that tulsi
gabbard could be a Russian asset no I
have I'm gonna leave others to comment
on that I have I have no comment at the
very least you think it was appropriate
for Hillary Clinton to insert herself
into the election in this way I have a
lot of respect for secretary what a
robot maybe that's why the room is empty
behind me but we're not gonna lie to you
it's not just Democrats you've gone off
the deep end with this stuff
remember Evan McMullen he's that guy
that Bill Kristol convinced a run for
president back in 2016
Moe and we were told as a serious
principled conservative unlike everyone
else and yet turns out he agrees with
Hillary here's his take on all this and
we're quoting I believe it's true tells
he Gabbard is with the Russians and the
Russians are with Tulsi Gabbard she
confirms it every time she opens her
mouth
end quote again no evidence what so ever
so then Trump weighed in and keep in
mind Trump was not on the same side as
Tulsi Gabbard much less Jill Stein but
yet he weighed in he said no he didn't
think that two of his political
opponents were spies well this sent
Washington into conniptions neocon
buffoon David Frum declared that the
denial itself proved conspiracy quote
Trump last night defended Jill Stein and
Tulsi Gabbard against charges of Russian
influence he wasn't supposed to do that
he was supposed to pretend they were not
all on the same team so it was all a
setup
according to David Fromm is that Tulsi
Gabbard the Soviet embassy in Mexico
City this is lunacy by the way but it's
not accidental lunacy it's lunacy in the
service of a purpose so last Friday we
had congresswoman Gabbard on the show
and we asked her what is this about and
she explained it about as well as
anybody ever has watch this I've never
heard anybody at Hillary Clinton's level
say something like that
and the reason why she's doing this is
because ultimately she knows that she
can't control me and that if I'm elected
president to find the Democratic nominee
and elected president that she won't be
able to control me she won't be able to
manipulate me she won't be able to
continue to work from behind the curtain
to continue these these regime change
wars that have been so costly in other
words it's about power and that
shouldn't be a surprised you or me or
anyone because in Washington everything
in the end is about power and for
generations a small group a bipartisan
group incidentally has run the country
and they've run it into the ground if
we're being honest about it
they've mismanaged the economy in case
you ever noticed they've wasted American
lives in pointless wars abroad they
forced weird and irrelevant gender
theory on a baffled nation while
hundreds of thousands of Americans died
of drug Odie's and they paid no notice
at all to that because they didn't care
we've never had a worse set of leaders
in this country that's what all the
drama is about that's what the
volatility comes from because our
leadership is terrible so it's not
surprising that this group the ones
who've wrecked the country don't take
criticism well don't like the program we
must be a spy